today's video is brought to you by
nordvpn making everything about your
internet experience just a bit better
more on them in a bit
gambling is one of Humanity's oldest
forms of entertainment it's all be based
on Greed the idea that you could earn
yourself a fortune overnight with just
one lucky spell at the tables every year
Millions visit the casinos palatial
Resorts that draw you in with dreams of
striking a rich and almost all of them
leave having gained nothing but a good
time one Gambler however had his own
idea for how to make a fortune from a
casino it didn't involve a lucky hand
though but a bomb one of the largest and
most complex improvised explosive
devices ever seen by American law
enforcement the bombers big gamble was
that the casino and the cops would
rather pay as Ransom than risk the lives
of innocent Casino patrons this is the
true story of the Harvey's Casino
bombing a crime so unbelievable that it
makes you wonder why they haven't made a
movie about it yet it has it all piled
some money a nationwide man hunt tons of
media attention and of course a big bang
foreign
State Line Nevada is barely a spec on
the map the unincorporated community on
the south shore of Lake Tahoe only has
850 year-round residents the only thing
it has going for it is its strategic
location as its name suggests it's right
on the border between California and
Nevada to the west of state line is the
California city of South Lake Tahoe one
of the state's biggest tourist
playgrounds the lake the sixth largest
in the U.S after the Great Lakes offers
plenty of fun during the summer while
the surrounding Sierra Nevada mountains
provide for some of the finest ski
slopes in America in the winter one
thing the city doesn't have though is
gambling since it's illegal in
California and that's where Stateline
comes in by 1980 there were four casinos
in Stateline conveniently located as
close to the California border as
possible the hotels on the California
side of the Border routinely organized
bus trips to and from the casinos a
profitable Enterprise for everyone but
the tourists one of these casinos was
Harvey's Wagon Wheel Resort and Casino
Harvey's was the first Casino opened in
the area in 1944 and 22 years later
owner Harvey gross opened a gambling
Palace to rival anything in Las Vegas at
the time an 11-story building with
multiple gaming floors and almost 200
hotel rooms it was Harvey gross's pride
and joy the culmination of a lifetime of
work for the one-time butcher from
Sacramento and it made him exceedingly
Rich at 5 30 a.m on August 26 1980 Bob
Vincent the casino's night shift
supervisor was heading down to the gift
shop to buy a packet of cigarettes when
he noticed a strange object sitting on
the floor in the storage area on the
second floor it was a large steel box
with a smaller box welded to the top of
it 28 toggle switches were the only
thing marring the smooth silver surfaces
of the object carefully numbered and
arranged in rows on top of the box was
an envelope with a typewritten note
inside it Vincent summoned Security
Supervisor Simon cabin who read the note
and realized to his horror that this
thing was a bomb supposedly with enough
explosive power to blow up the entire
building and everyone in it
[Music]
by the time Dawn broke over the
mountains the scene around Harvey's
Casino was chaotic the entire resort was
immediately evacuate many guests
standing outside in their bathrobes or
without shoes on while they awaited
transportation to a local high school
for temporary lodging police cordoned
off the street while bomb squad officers
and federal agents poured over the side
examining the device in detail their
prognosis wasn't good the bomb was so
complex in its construction that there
was no way that it was fake as what
officer noted no one would go through
all of that effort and then fill the
thing up with kitty litter what was
worse the thing was loaded with booby
traps it could not be moved drilled into
or opened without setting it off for
most of the people looking at it
including some of the country's foremost
explosive experts it was both the
largest and most complex improvised
explosive device that ever encountered
investigators turned to the note that
came with the bomb like the device
itself the note was far more complicated
than the usual handwritten this is a
bomb pay me a ransom or else that they
were used to seeing it was three type
person
which bragged about how complex the
device was and provided extraordinarily
detailed instructions for delivering
three million dollars in Ransom money
via helicopter to a remote spot in the
mountains north of town even if the
ransom was played the note claimed that
the bomb couldn't be disarmed not even
by the person that made it what they
could do however was provide
instructions on how to turn off the
motion sensing detector so that it could
be safely removed and detonated off-site
the FBI agents in charge are enter
Harvey gross to see if he was willing to
pay the ransom now Bobby obviously
didn't want to see his Casino blown up
but he also didn't want anybody to get
hurt trying to move the bomb after all
they only had the bombers word that it
could be erended safe enough to move
without going off with that being the
case the casino magnate told the FBI
that he wouldn't give those sons of any
of his money at midnight that night a
helicopter took off from Lake Tahoe
Airport heading into the mountains to
look for a strobe light that was the
signal from the bomber for the
helicopter to land on board was the
Branson actually cut up newspaper with
about a thousand dollars in cash mixed
in make it look real the FBI also hoped
to capture the bomber at the drop-off
point for the ransom but there was a
mix-up the helicopter went to the wrong
place it was forced to return
empty-handed the governor of Nevada a
Robert list went over the radio to
announce that the authorities were still
willing to make the ransom drop but the
bomber just needed to contact them again
in the meantime though there was still a
gigantic bomb ticking down to detonation
inside of Harvey's and they needed to
figure out what to do about it so as
Millie's situation near the coffee shop
the airport wherever and there's that
sign free Wi-Fi it's got those five
strong bars a reception but should you
click on it could it be a trap could
someone be looking to intercept your
data get into your personal information
your bank account
Etc well tell you what you can use that
Wi-Fi totally safely if you have the
precaution of having nordvpn installed
on your PC or Mac your phone whatever
just fire up Nord hit connect go on to
that Wi-Fi and do whatever you want
online because no one is breaking
through nord's incredible encryption
giving other people's eyes off your
browsing and that's all good thus have
only been your out and about the best
thing for me about a VPN is more
streaming options close Netflix fire up
Nord choose America and boom a whole new
range of Netflix staff new home page new
shows it's all there works for a bunch
of streaming services plus you can use
nordvpn on six devices all major
platforms are supported so look get the
safety get the cool extra stuff
streaming downloading games in regions
where you're not supposed to be able to
get them
Etc go to nordvpn.com forward slash bio
and you'll get a two-year plan with four
months for free and now back to today's
video
[Music]
24 hours after the bomb scare started
the eyes of America's media were all
trained on State Line beyond the
quarter-mile Cordon established by the
police a large crowd of curious
onlookers had gathered most of them
probably hoping to see the building blow
up some enterprising businessmen had
started printing t-shirts that said I
got bombed Harvey's and was doing brisk
business selling them to caucus rumors
swirled around how the gamblers were
placing bets and the other still open
casinos about whether or not the bomb
was going to go off across the street at
the Sahara some of the nation's leading
explosive experts gathered at the
incident command post they included Army
EOD technicians civilian scientists who
designed bombs for the military even
representatives from the newly created
nuclear emergency search team Nest whose
job it is to respond to criminal
incidents where nuclear weapons might be
involved they together with police and
FBI bomb experts debated about what to
do with the Harvey's Bond every idea
that was floated for disarming the
device was shot down as unworkable
finally a civilian who worked for the
Navy Leonard Wilson said suggested a
solution that sounded insane at first
and that was more explosives the idea
was to place a shaped charge of the
plastic explosive C4 on the device when
detonated the charge would decapitate
the brain of the bomb located in the
smaller box stacked on top of all of the
explosives before it had a chance to
trigger the wiring that would set off
the bomb it was a risky plan but it
seems like the only one they could come
up with that had any chance of disarming
the bomb that afternoon a very nervous
police bomb Tech placed the specially
constructed charge next bomb precisely
checking the Angles and distances to
ensure that it was in the correct
position at 3 45 PM almost 35 hours
after the bomb was placed the police set
off the C4 it was immediately obvious
that the attempt to disarm the bomb had
failed the atar payload detonated
ripping through the casino floor and the
hotel rooms above the windows of the
harass Casino across the street were
blown out as a cloud of billowing debris
and Rubble fell all over the place the
crowd of onlookers cheered and laughed
as they watched the bomb go off the
explosion was covered from all sides by
news cameras and the footage was soon
broadcast worldwide fortunately nobody
was hurt but the building was severely
damaged the blast leaving crater five
stories deep within the building
investigators spent weeks sifting
through the debris looking for parts of
the bomb alongside Personnel from the
casino who were looking for over a
million dollars worth of cash and casino
chips that had been left behind when the
building was evacuated and were now just
lying around everywhere amazingly the
bomb hadn't knocked the casino down and
hadn't even put all of the slot machines
and gaming tables out of action Harvey's
partially reopened two days after the
bombing and went back into full
operation the next year after repairs
totaling 18 million dollars with the
immediate crisis over investigators now
had one very important question left to
answer
who was responsible for this
among the 200 000 Hungarian refugees
that fled their native country after the
failed Uprising against the communist
government in 1956 was a 35 year old man
named Janos Burgess and his wife
Elizabeth later Burgers I would later
tell people that he'd flown for the axis
during World War II had been taken
prisoner by the Soviet Union but no
evidence has surfaced to verify these
claims the couple moved to Fresno a
California City about 250 miles south of
Lake Tahoe and anglicized their names as
many immigrants do Big John as he became
known started a successful landscaping
business while Elizabeth managed the
family-owned restaurant The Villa Basque
they had two sons John Jr known as
Johnny and James or Jimmy by the early
1970s it seemed they were living every
immigrant family's dream of success in
their new home Big John was a
millionaire with a home on 15 acres of
land outside of Fresno a fleet of
Mercedes cars even his own airplane that
he taught himself to fly but all was not
well in the Burgess family Big John had
a notoriously bad temper and routinely
beat both his wife and his children with
his fists coat hangers boots whatever he
had readily to hand both Jonah and
Elizabeth began drinking heavily and the
more they drank the more they fought
Elizabeth finally had enough and filed
for divorce in 1973. two years later she
was found dead in a field behind the
family home while officially ruled a
suicide an intentional overdose of
alcohol and Valium her sons found the
manner of death highly suspicious they
believed their father had killed her
around the time Elizabeth died Big John
seemed to go off the rails completely he
abruptly sold his landscaping business
and began to spend more and more time
gambling at the casinos up in Lake Tahoe
his favorite place was Harvey's Wagon
Wheel where he was treated like a high
roller given a complimentary hotel suite
befriended by the staff he even spent a
weekend at Harvey Grocer's Ranch in 1976
where he was given a chance to fly the
casino boss's helicopter he began
spending more and more money especially
at the blackjack tables and routinely
left his sons to fend for themselves for
weeks at a time while he gambled away
the family fortune up in Tahoe by the
end of the 1970s Big John was running
out of and he was racking up debt in
1978 villabasque burned to the ground
police suspected it was torched
liberally for the insurance money which
merges promptly lost at the casinos debt
collectors from Harvey's began showing
up at his home looking for payment that
they were owed he desperately tried to
make back what it lost by placing still
more wages which only put him further in
the hole even his health was beginning
to fail him in 1979 he was diagnosed
with abdominal cancer which has a high
mortality rate even today let alone back
then with apparently nothing left to
lose Bert has decided to embark on an
audacious scheme to reverse his sagging
fortunes to get all the money back that
it lost and with interest
John Burgess had always been something
of a tinkerer his Workshop was full of
half-finished projects and ideas he was
very good with tools he was comfortable
around Dynamite as well and it turned
out that getting his hands on half a ton
of the stuff was the easy part of his
scheme he and his two sons simply drove
up to an unguarded construction site in
the middle of the night and stole it
from an explosive step over there Berger
stored the dynamite in his walk-in
freezer while he built the bomb Big John
spent months laboring over his device
carefully assembling every piece by hand
he rigged the bomb with eight separate
triggering mechanisms including half a
dozen booby traps to prevent the bomb
squad from disarming it he attached
aluminum foil to the steel casing of the
bomb and wired it so that if someone
drilled into the casing it would
complete the circuit and set the device
off he wired the screws used to secure
the lid of the bomb to prevent them from
being unscrewed even wired up afloat
from a toilet system that would set the
bomb off if the bomb squad attempted to
flood the trigger mechanism with water
or foam the deadliest trap of course was
the motion sensor that prevented the
device from being being moved Leicester
go off this posed the greatest risk to
the occupants of Harvey's as it was
perfectly plausible for the bomb to
blurb accidentally if it was jostled by
anything from someone falling on it to
an earthquake Burgess chose Harvey's as
his Target because it was where he had
lost his money gambling an estimated 750
000 when his two sons refused to help
him put the bomb inside the casino Big
John Enlisted the help of two men who
used to work at his landscaping business
Terry Hall and Bill Brown the final
member of the conspiracy was burgess's
girlfriend Joan Williams who wrote The
Ransom note and helped transport the
various participants around Lake Tahoe
getting the bomb into the casino was
easy too early in the morning of August
26th Burgess Hall and brown rolled up to
Harvey's in a white cargo van wearing
workman's coveralls they wheeled the
device right into the building under a
canvas tarp that had IBM printed on it
figuring it was a piece of computer
equipment or perhaps a new photocopier
the staff at the casino didn't pay any
attention to it as the men placed the
bomb armed it and then left by the time
the bomb was discovered half an hour
later the three were long gone after
that everything had gone wrong The
Ransom drop was a failure because the
helicopter never showed up the elaborate
scavenger hunt described in the ransom
note was a ruse burgess's plan was to
overpower the helicopter pilot flying
The Ransom when it arrived at the first
drop point and then steal the chopper
flying the money to a second location
and taking off with it by car but even
if the helicopter with the ransom had
shown up this would never have worked in
addition to the ransom being bugged the
I was an FBI agent hidden aboard the
chopper armed with an MP5 submachine gun
and orders to protect the pilot no
matter what as likely then that John
Burgess would have been shot dead that
night had the meet-up actually taken
place in the end burge's machinations
had simply been too complicated to work
the bomb was so cleverly constructed
that the bomb squad wasn't going to risk
trying to move it meaning that Harvey
gross had no interest in paying the
ransom and the instructions of the
chopper pilot were so complex that he
got lost and the ransom drop never had a
chance to take place the next day of
course any chance of getting a ransom
disappeared when the attempt to disarm
the bomb failed and it blew up Harvey so
they all had to go home empty-handed
still all things considered they were
fortunate no evidence had been left
behind linking any of them to the
bombing and they stood a good chance of
getting away with it assuming of course
that nobody talked
[Music]
despite a five hundred thousand dollar
reward put up by the casino owners of
Stateline the FBI had no concrete leads
into who had placed the device at
Harvey's this told investigators that
the culprits were likely very close a
family for instance as 1980 became 1981
one of the largest most expensive
investigations in FBI history was going
absolutely nowhere then in June of 1981
a Fresno man named Danny De Perry
decided to take his shot at claiming the
half million dollar award he told
investigating agents about a story as
ex-girlfriend Kelly Cooper had told him
you see oh one of Kelly's other exes was
John burge's Junior and Kelly had been
present the first time Jimmy told his
brother about the scheme their father
was cooking up to extort money from
Harvey's Casino when she read in the
newspaper that fifty thousand dollars
worth of dynamite had been stolen from a
construction site not long after she
suspected the Burgess family had
something to do with it and apparently
told Dany all about her suspicions this
probably wouldn't have meant anything by
itself but it just happened that the FBI
had already talked to Johnny Burge is
because a white cargo van registered in
his name had been seen in the parking
lot of a Lake Tahoe Hotel the night
before the bomb had been placed in the
casino and the Agents felt that the
story he gave them for wire was up there
was highly suspicious after that the
whole story started coming out FBI
agents looked into Big John Burgess and
found lots to be suspicious about the
cabultive gambling the fire at his
restaurant believed to be an insurance
arson job the mysterious death of his
ex-wife Elizabeth is bad temper and his
affinity for building things then of
course you had the fact that Joan
Williams's car had crashed in the Lake
Tahoe area the night The Ransom drop had
taken place and the fact that Johnny
Burgers had been pulled over for
speeding on a highway leading from Lake
Tahoe back to Fresno the next day his
brother was in the passenger seat and
his father was in the back on August
14th 1981 FBI agents brought Johnny and
Jimmy Burgess in for interrogation after
three hours of stonewalling both
brothers decided that they weren't about
to go to jail for a father that had
abused them and mistreated them their
entire lives they told the cops
everything the next day Big John and
Joan Williams were arrested incredibly
at the time of his arrest John Burgess
was planning another bomb in fact he'd
already stolen more Dynamite
in March 1985 after almost four years of
legal maneuvering John Berger senior was
convicted on eight of the nine federal
charges against him in connection to the
Harvey's Casino bombing he was sentenced
to life in prison dying there in 1996.
to the end Big John never came clean his
ego wouldn't allow him to deny that he'd
built the bomb which everyone admitted
was ingenious but he would always claim
someone else had forced him to do it a
mysterious mobster the prosecutors said
was a pigment of his imagination Bill
Brown and Terry hall both received seven
years in prison for their part in the
bomb plot so did Joan Williams but her
conviction was later overturned on
appeal Johnny and Jimmy Burgess in
exchange for testifying against the rest
of the group including their father
received immunity and walked free not
having spent so much as one night behind
bars for their part in the bowling the
Harvey's Casino bombing slipped off the
front page not long after it happened as
the country turned into Ronald Reagan's
election as president and all the
headlines of the 1980s that followed
Harvey gross died in 1983. his Casino
was bought by corporate Casino Titan
Caesar's entertainment which still
operates the now much larger Harvey's
casino and State Line one place that
hasn't forgotten the Harvey's case is
the FBI at the time the Harvey's bomb
was the largest IED ever set off on
American soil and has since only been
surpassed by the far more Infamous
bombings of the World Trade Center in
1993 in the Oklahoma City bomb in 1995.
FBI bomb techs built a Plexiglas model
of Harvey's bomb that is still used to
dare as a training tool at the FBI's
Training Academy in Quantico Virginia
perhaps the scariest part about this
incident is the fact that even all these
years later most explosive experts
familiar oh with the case still aren't
sure if there was a way to safely disarm
the device John Burge is built without
it exploding if there is such a thing as
an undefeatable bomb this was it and
that of course opens up the possibility
however unlikely that someone might do
it again
foreign